this is actually what we're talking
about something else we're doing here
that i don't know if we're saying it
right now
but it's it's about dating and it's that
idea
we were looking at how to frame
something and the conversation started
with well what's that one moment where
it took off and that's what i was
exactly where you are there's not one
moment where it takes off it's an entire
experience from when you sit down it's
the entire thing it's not just because
it does it puts this really weird
pressure on romantic yeah yes it doesn't
have to be that men are the romantics
and if you don't happen to stumble upon
the subject that she really wanted to
hear about and connect with you then it
all failed this is a disgusting amount
of pressure and it's really unrealistic
about how a good relationship will go or
even start yeah i don't know because i
feel like
you guys are saying the pressures on men
but at the end of the day like
the men have the decision who they marry
so i feel like the pressure is a lot on
the women do you think who makes a
decision who who decides who's gonna be
in a committed long-term relationship
technical the woman has to say yes but
the men the man can like decide
you know if he wants to put a ring on it
depends on the man depends on who who
we're talking about i think a lot i
think a lot of women get into this idea
that
um that men are the ones who are in
control of like commitment when in fact
it's usually women are in control of sex
and the and the commitment at this stage
um simply because the guys that women
want to commit with are usually the ones
who are hesitant they tend to be the
more high value guys and so so it seems
like men have more choice or men have
the have the selectivity you know power
of selectivity well yeah the guys that
you like the apex example at the top of
the pyramid that's if that's the you
know the guy that you're after then yeah
they probably do but average guys don't
have anything near that kind of
selectivity well let's have this
conversation average
okay
[Music]